Evet sevgili 9. sınıflar ilk ünitenin
ilk kısmını tamamlamıştık. Matematik
nerede işimize yarıyor ya da bu
matematik ilk ne zaman bulundu? Bu
dersimizde ilk olarak bu soruyu
cevaplayacağız. Birlikte ilk ünitemizin
yani fizik bilimi ve kariyer keşfin
artık son kısmına giriş yapıyoruz.
Tarihte fizikte kimler bilime katkı
sağladı? Başka bilimlerden hangi bilim
insanları hangi dönemlerde ne gibi
gelişmelere katkı sağladı? Bunları bir
konuşacağız. Biraz böyle popüler bilim
sohbeti gibi olacak. Ardından da hızlı
bir şekilde bilim merkezlerinden
bahsedip 8 tane soru çözeceğim sana. Bu
üniteyile alakalı tüm soruları nasıl
yorumlamamız gerektiğini dersini
tamamladığında öğrenmiş olacaksın. Bu
ünite zaten tamamen sözel. İlk
dersimizde fizik nedir ve alt dalları
nelerdir? Ne gibi çalışma alanları
vardır? Bunları konuşmuştuk. Bu
dersimizde de biraz bilime dair sohbet
edip sorularımızı çözeceğiz. Dayan. İlk
üniteyi tamamlıyoruz bu video ile
birlikte. Sonra zaten yazılı öncesi
ikinci ünitenin sadece ilk giriş kısmını
anlatacağım ve bol bol tekrarlar ve
örneklerle çalışmalarımıza devam
edeceğiz. Hazırsan hemen derse geçmeden
videoyu beğendin. Kanala abone değilsen
abone oldun. Birlikte bu dersimizi bomba
gibi tamamlıyoruz.
[Müzik]
Fiziğin doğanın kanunu olduğunu, doğanın
kurallarını fiziğin söylediğini
konuşmuştuk ve biz bu doğadan, evrenden
keyif alabilmek için bu oyunun
kurallarını bilmemiz gerekiyor demiştik.
Fizik şimdi bize hep sanki formüller
silsilesi gibi geliyor. Oysa
formüllerden ziyade bu formüllerin her
birinin en temelinde düşünce yaptığını
bilmemiz gerekiyor dedik. Yani fizik en
temelde felsefeyle, sorgulamayla, merak
duymayla alakalıydı. Şimdi sana hızlıca
tarihte bu merak duygularını kimler
böyle köreltmeden bizlere sunabildi?
Kimler böyle bize bir katkı sağlayabildi
bilimsel? Bunlardan bahsedeceğim. İlk
olarak bizim bugün günümüzde bildiğimiz
en eski insanların bir araya geldiği,
toplandığı yer milattan önce oninlerde
Göbeklitepe. Hatta Evrim ağacının bir
videosunda Göbeklitepe'ye çok yakın 30
kre yakınlarda bir yer daha bulunduğunu
bahsetti. Ben de ilerleyen süreçlerde
inan bana böyle bilim merkezlerini, bu
arkeolojik kalıntıları incelemek için
bir tur yapmak istiyorum. O da elbette
siz öğrencilerimin desteğiyle olacak.
Böyle bilim merkezlerini gezip sonra
Zeduava stüdyolarına kendi bilim
merkezimi kurmayı hayal ediyorum.
Bakalım zaman neler gösterir. Oralara
artık çok fazla girmeden şundan
bahsedeyim. Milattan önce 4000'lerde
insanlar avcı toplayıcı zihniyetten
çıkıp yerleşik hayata geçiyorlar. Nin
lehrinin, suyun yanına oturup tarım
yapıyorlar. Tarım yapınca da e bu
dataları tutmaya ihtiyaç duyuyorlar.
Bunun için Türkçe, matematik yani
aslında yazı ortaya çıkıyor ve
matematiği buluyorlar. Yani matematik ne
zaman karşımıza geldi? Milattan önce
4000'lerde ilk kez matematiğe ihtiyaç
duyduk. Bu matematikle birlikte ne
yaptılar? İlk vergi sistemini
oluşturdular. Yani buradan ben tarımdan
ne kadar işte buğday ürettim, bunun ne
kadarını sattım, ne kadarı gelecek.
Bunun için ihtiyaç duydukları matematiği
sayma sistemine döktüler ve elimizdeki
şu parmaklarımızdaki üç boğundumdan
yararlanarak 4 kere 3 12 5 parmak var.
60'lı sayma sistemini geliştirdi
Sümerler ve ilk kez okul mantığını
geliştirdiler. Matematik, sanat, yazı
buralarda gelişmeye başlandı. Milattan
önce 2500'lerde antik Mısırlıları
görüyoruz. Onlar da bu 60'lı sayma
sistemini tercih etmeyip yaptıkları şeyi
bugünkü kullandığımız 10'lu sayma
sistemlerini geliştirdiler ve bununla
birlikte aynı zamanda hepimizin bugün
bile muzdarip olduğu takvimleme
mantığını ortaya koydular. Takvimi,
planlamayı geliştirdiler. Onun dışında
artık yaklaşıyoruz milattan önce
500'lerde antik Yunanlılarda. Antik
Yunan deyince lütfen bugünkü Yunanistan
sınırını değil o dönemde birçok savaşan
olduğunu düşünerek aslında bugünkü
topraklarımızın da antik Yunanlılarda
olduğunu bilmeni istiyorum. Antik
Yunanlılarda felsefe başlıyor. Felsefe
bilgiyi arayan, bilgiyi sorgulayan
demektir. Felsefeci ya da filozof bilen,
düşünen demektir. O dönem insanlar
etrafını sorgulamaya başlıyor. Hatta
Tales bildiğimiz gibi filozoflardan
kendisi Aydın'da yaşıyor. Peki Tales ne
yaptı? Etrafını şöyle kurcaladıktan
sonra dedi ki ya bunların en temelinde
ne var diye bunu merak etti. O dönemki
bu tartışmaların sonucunda kimisi demiş
ki her maddenin en temelinde ateş var.
Kimisi demiş ki her maddenin en
temelinde su var. Tabii biz bugün ne
diyoruz? Maddeler atomlardan oluşuyor
diyoruz. İşte bu atom mevzusu daha
1900'lü yıllarda konuşulacak. Hatta bu
dönemde bir Democratos diye arkadaş var.
O diyor, "Atomus antik Yunancada
bölünemez, parçalanamaz demek. İlk kez o
bahsediyor ama bir daha bir 2000 yıl
falan kimse konuşmuyor desek yeridir."
Pisagor, Aristo, Öklit bu arkadaşlarımız
matematikle geometriyle ilgileniyor.
Hatta Pisagorü seninle bir ünite sonra
vektörlerde işlem yaparken kullanacağız.
Üçgenlerden bir teorem kendisi. Aristo
bir okul kuruyor ve okulun girişine
geometri bilmeyen giremez yazıyor. Öklit
ilk olarak ışığı sorguluyor. Görme
eylemini sorguluyor. Diyor ki gözümden
çıkan ışınlar sayesinde görüyorum diyor
ve aynı zamanda geometriye bir katkı
sağlıyor. Arşimet var bilmemiz gereken.
Arşimet bizim için yaptığı şey şu ki ilk
olarak senin ortaokulda LGS'de gördüğün
basit makineler düzeneğini geliştiriyor.
Kaldıraç sistemlerini yapıyor. Hatta
diyor ki bana öyle uzun bir sopa
verirseniz dünyayı bile yerinden
oynatırım diyor. Ayrıca aynı zamanda
kral tacının saf altından olup
olmadığını deneyimleyerek bunun nasıl
bulunacağının yöntemini çiziyor ve bugün
bizim bildiğimiz öz kütle kavramını o
gün formülle ifade etmese de ta milattan
önce 500'de konuşmuş oluyor. Yani
insanoğlu milattan önce 500'lerde doğayı
sorgulayarak maddenin ne olduğunu
anlamaya çalışıyor. Özetle 0la 1000
yıllar arasında ne oluyor? Batlamyus
diye biri var. Güneşin gelme ışınlarını
kontrol etmek amacıyla aletler
geliştiriyor, cetveller üretiyor. Hatiya
ilk bilim insanlarından bildiğimiz.
Kendisi bir matematikçi ve maalesef o
dönemde yakılarak öldürülüyor. Kadının
böyle toplumda yeri yoktur diyerek
öldürülüyor. Bugün bile maalesef bu
zihniyet hala hayatımızda var. Sanki
matematiği illa erkek anlatacak ya da
kadınlar meslek sahibi olmayacak diye
bir zihniyet maalesef günümüzde bile
devam etmekte. Harez mi var? Harmi
söylentilere göre Çin'den sıfırı bulup
getiriyor ve algoritma yani senin
matematikte göreceğin o formüllerin
mantığını Harezmi 1000li yıllara
gelmeden konuşmuş oluyor. Ve bu yıllar
arasında biliyorsun ki Müslüman bir
ülkede olduğumuz için Kur'an-ı Kerim
geliyor insanoğlunun hayatına. Kur'an-ı
Kerim'deki ayetlerden de yararlanarak
insanları iyice sorgulamaya başlıyor.
İslamiyet altın çağına ulaşıyor. İşte ne
diyor ayetlerde? İşte güneşe bakmaz
mısın? Sorgulamaz mısın? Düşünmez misin?
Ayla güneşin hizasından bahsedince
insanoğlu bugüne kadar yapabildiği tek
şey olan gökyüzünü incelemeye daha
derinlemesine devam ediyor. Ve karşımıza
İbn Heysam çıkıyor. İbn Heysam şu ana
kadar bizim 9. sınıfta konuşmamız
gereken en önemli isimlerden. Çünkü
bildiğimiz literatüre uygun araştırma
yapan, deney ve gözlemleri bize nasıl
yapmamız gerektiğini söyleyen ilk bilim
insanı olarak geçiyor hayata. Çünkü İbn
İsam diyor ki "Yahu ben her şeyden şüphe
etmeliyim. Gerçek bir bilgiye ulaşmak
istiyorsam ancak bunu şüpheyle
yapabilirim. Bırak gördüğümü, duyduğumu,
başkalarından kendi dediğimden bile
şüphe duymalıyım ki gerçeğe ilk ulaşma
aşamam şüphe duymaktır diyor. Kendinden
bile şüphe etmen gerektiğini söylüyor.
Hani fizik bilimdi ve bilim gözlem ve
deneye dayalıydı ya. İlk gözlem ve deney
mantığını oluşturan İbn Heysem oluyor. O
güne kadar insanlar görme eyleminin
gözlerimizden çıkan ışınlarla olduğunu
söylüyorlar. Fakat İbn İsam diyor ki,
"Bu böyle olamaz. şüpheli yaklaşıyor.
Karanlıkta en azından bir şeyler
görebilmeliydim diye görme eyleminin
nasıl gerçekleştiğini sorguluyor. Gözlem
ve deneyler yapıyor. Karanlık oda deneyi
yaparak karanlık odanın minnacık bir
kısmına delik açarak iğne deliği, pinle
kamerasını bugünkü kameraların ilk
versiyonu prototipini oluşturmuş oluyor.
Buradan da yola çıkarak aslında görme,
gözümden çıkan ışınlarla değil,
ışınların etrafındaki nesnelerden
yansıyıp gözüme ulaşmasıyla oluşur diye
gözün yapısını çiziyor bu adam. Düşün ki
İbn Heysen bizim için gerçekten önemli
isimlerden biri. Hem ilk bilim insanı
olması vesilesiyle, bilimin hangi
aşamalarla yapılması vesilesiyle, hem de
burada optiğe dair büyük bir atılımda
bulunması sebebiyle önemli bir isimdir.
Fiziğin alt dallarından optik Kur'an-ı
Kerim'in insanoğlunun hayatına
gelmesiyle birlikte gelişti diyebiliriz.
Aynı zamanda bu dönemde meslek olarak
ele almamız gerekirse en çok para
kazanan mesleklerden bir tanesinin
ismini veriyorum. Çevirmenlik. Çünkü
bilim hep ezelden bu yana göç etmiş.
Hani dedim ya Haypetiya öldürülmüş.
Haypetiya döneminde yani milattan sonra
300'lü yıllarda İskenderiye kütüphanesi
yakılıyor. Hatta diyorlar ki işte
nehirlerden mürekkep renkleri aktı.
laciverte bulandı nehirler diye. Orada
bilim merkezleri yakılınca, kütüphaneler
yakılınca aslında bilim göç ediyor.
Bilim göç edince bilim dil değiştiriyor.
Bilimin dil değiştirmesi de çevirmenlere
büyük bir fırsat oluşturmuş oluyor. O
dönemin en yüksek maaşlarını çevirmenler
alıyor. Bugün bile bilimi öğrenmek
istiyorsan şu an bilimin ana dili
İngilizce. Dili bilmek zorundasın.
İngilizceyi bilirsen sana İbn Heysem
diyorum. İngilizce araştırırsan bir de
Türkçe araştırsan aradaki farkı, kaynak
farkını çok bariz görebilirsin. Bizim
için önemli olan şey bilimde gerçek
bilgiye ulaşmak istiyorsak bilimin
dilini de bilmek diyebilirim. 1400'lü
yıllara geliyoruz. Ya hocam neden
aralarda bir isim söylemedin bana?
1000'den 1400'e zıpladın. Şurada
1200'lerde hazini var. Hazini de en
hassas ölçüm yapacak teraziyi buluyor
bizlere. Orada yine öz kütle kavramıyla
alakalı bir çalışmalar yapılıyor. Fakat
bu dönemde ne oluyor? Dünya genelinde
bir kara veba yaşanıyor. Yani bizim
pandemi sadece bizim başımıza gelmedi.
Şu tarihe bir bakacak olursak
kronolojide dönem dönem dünyaya böyle
felaketler geldiğini, salgınlar
geldiğini gözlemleyebilirsin. O dönemde
insan sayısında ciddi bir azalma oluyor.
Bir de ulaşım aracı olarak bu sürece
kadar en çok kullanılan şey arşimetle
birlikte gemiler oluyor. Gemi sayesinde
ne oluyor biliyor musun? 1400'lü
yıllarda yani 15. yüzyılda Amerika
keşfediliyor. Amerika keşfedilince
yoldan altın bulunuyor. Düşün o kadar
fazla insan yok o dönemde Amerika'da.
Altınla birlikte ve nüfusun azalmasıyla
birlikte aslında dünya bir
zenginleşiyor. Ve tabii ki bu 1400'lü
yıllarda biliyorsun İstanbul'un fethi
yani Osmanlı İmparatorluğu var. Antik
Yunan falan bitmiş oluyor bu dönemde.
Osmanlı İmparatorluğu hakim dünyaya.
Kimler varmış bilimsel olarak ele
almamız gerekirse Amerika keşfedildi.
Kopernik diye bir isim var. Kopernik
evreni inceliyor. Uzay boşluğunu
inceliyor. Ve insanoğlu o güne kadar
Kur'an-ı Kerim'in de etkisiyle birlikte
ya her şey insan için yaratılmış, insan
merkezdedir diye dünya merkezli bir
evren sistemi hayal ediyorlar. Gökyüzünü
inceleyebildikleri kadarıyla bütün gök
cisimleri güneş dahil dünyanın etrafında
dönüyor diyorlar. Fakat Kopernik diyor
ki sanırım dünya merkezli değil de güneş
merkezli bir sistem var diyor. Tiko
Birahedli diye bir arkadaşımız var. ilk
gözlem evini kuran insanlardan ve gözlem
evini kurarak uzayı inceleyerek yaklaşık
9.000 sayfa not alıyor. Burada bir cisim
var. Bu buraya geldi, bu buraya geldi
diye çizimler yapıyor. Onun öğrencisi
bilim merkezinde yer alan araştırma
görevlisi gibi düşün Kepler Tiko
vefatından sonra o 9.000 sayfalık
yazılarını, notlarını yaklaşık 6 yıl
inceliyor, okuyor ve capler evrenin üç
yasasını, gezegen sisteminin üç
yasasından bahsediyor. Ya bunlar
dairesel dönmüyor aslında. Bunlar
eliptik bir yörünge takip ediyor. İşte
gezegenlerin kütlesine bağlı değil.
Etrafında ne kadar süre yol alacağı
diye. Kepler bize bunları anlatıyor.
Gilbert var. Gilbert bu arkadaşlardan
bağımsız bir şekilde 1500'lerinin
ortalarında bize neyden bahsediyor
biliyor musun? magnetten, magnetizmadan
bahsediyor. Demagnet diye bir kitap
çıkartıyor. Hatta Kehribar taşının nasıl
böyle kedi tüyünü falan çektiğini
sorguluyor. Hani ortaokulda yaptığın
deneylerden hatırlarsın. Böyle tarağı
sürtüyoruz saçımıza. Bir
elektrostatiklenme yapıyoruz ve kağıdı
çekebiliyoruz. Kehribar taşı da tam
olarak bunu yaptığı için Gilbert bunun
araştırmasına giriyor. Onun dışında
1500'lerin sonunda Galileo'yu görüyoruz.
Galileo bizim için ikinci önemli isim.
9. sınıf müfredatımızda. Çünkü Galileo
ne yapıyor? Bir sonraki konumuz olan
kuvvet hareketin temellerini atıyor. 10.
sınıfta da ağır matematiğini yapacağımız
deneyleri Galileo yapıyor. 1500'lerin
sonunda bir tepeye çıkıp Pisa kulesi, bu
da bir hikaye, söylentiye göre Pisa
kulesinden farklı iki kütleyi bırakıyor
ve bunlar neden aynı anda yere ulaşıyor?
Kütleden bağımsız neden bunlar yere
düşüyor diye bunları sorguluyor. Hareket
kavramlarının mutlak olup olmadığını
sorguluyor. İlk olarak hareket deyince
aklına ne gelecekti hocam? Mekanik
gelecekti. Ha demek ki fiziğin alt
dallarından op konuşuldu. Sırada mekanik
konuşulmaya başlandı. Galileo sadece
hareket denklemlerini değil aynı zamanda
ilk teleskobu yapıyor. İlk kez gökyüzünü
net bir şekilde gözlemliyor ve
yıldızların sonsuz olduğunu görüyor. Ne
kadar korkutucu düşün. bir sınır varmış
gibi düşünüyorsun yüzyıllar boyu ve
teleskop sayesinde sınırsız bir evrene
bakıyorsun. yıldızların sınırsız
olduğunu aydaki lekeleri gözlemliyor ve
buradan yola çıkarak da aslında
Kopernik'in, Kepler'in konuşmaya
çalıştığı yahu dünya merkezli değilmiş
bu gezegen sistemi, güneş merkezliymiş
hikayesini resmediyor. İspat etmesine
rağmen insanlar teleskopla açıp bakıp
güneşin etrafında dünyanın döndüğünü
gözlemleyebilecek olmasına rağmen
kendisi idamla yargılanıyor ve ev
hapsine çarpıtılıyor. Düşünün o dönemde.
Yani sadece uzayla değil, sadece fizikle
değil, sadece matematikle değil, birçok
disiplinle bir arada uğraşıyor. İlk
termometre örneğini de Galileo yapıyor.
1600'lü yıllarda Hook'u görüyoruz.
Robert Hook senin yine ortaokulda
gördüğün dinamometre, yaylı sistemler
yapmıştın ya. Onların geliştirmesini
yapıyor ve kuvveti tanımlıyor. Hugance
var. Dalgalarla ilgili konuşuyor.
Şimdilik bunu konuşmamız için erken. 10.
sınıfta tanımlayabiliriz ancak. Halley
kuyruklu yıldız. Belki bilirsin. Hley
kuyruklu yıldızının hikayesi şu. Yine
matematiğe dayanarak Hley diyor ki ya bu
yıldız atıyorum 60 yıl sonra buradan
yine geçecek. 60 yıl sonra Halley çoktan
öldükten sonra gerçekten yaptığı
matematik sayesinde evet diyorlar. Bu
yıldız o kuyruklu yıldızın adına da
Halley'in anısına itafen Halley
deniliyor. Hatta bugün Heley
çikolatalarının üstünde de o kuyruklu
yıldız amblemini görebilirsin. Bu da
reklam değil. bahsedeyim. Bir genel
kültür olarak aklında kalsın. Bizim
konuşacağımız, bu yılki göreceğimiz
fizik konularından Pascal ve Torielli
ile birlikte basınç kavramlarına giriş
yapıyoruz. Yani katılar nasıl basınç
uygular, sıvılar nasıl hareket eder,
rüzgar ne oluyor da nereden nereye
gidiyor? Bunların tanımlamalarını,
dinamiğini bu arkadaşlar 1600'lü
yıllarda konuşuyor. Bunların dönem
arkadaşı olan Newton bir diğer önemli
ismimiz. Çünkü kuvvet hareketin hatta
klasik fiziğin hatta mekaniğin babası
olarak tanımlıyoruz. Sebebi şu. Onun
öncesindeki var olan Galileo'dan,
Kep'lerden yararlanarak Newton o dönem
şunu açıklıyor. Diyor ki, "Elma dünyaya
düşüyor da dünya neden elmaya düşmüyor?
Ya da ay neden dünyaya düşmüyor? gelip
yapışmıyor. Bunları sorguluyor ve bize
kuvvetin matematiksel tanımını yapıyor.
Ve bu kuvvetin tanımı sayesinde
etrafında gördüğün, gözlemleyebildiğin,
hareket eden her şeyi F = ma denklemine
sığdırabiliyor. Bu kadar muazzam bir iş
yapıyor. Bu arada Newton sadece yine
fizikle ilgilenmiyor. Aslında bunları
tanımlayabilmesi için ağır bir
matematik, yeni bir matematik getiriyor.
Türev integral diye. O dönemde ne
yapıyor? simyayla yani kimyanın o
başlangıç kısmıyla ilgileniyor.
Ölümsüzlüğü bulmaya çalışıyor. Başka İbn
İsem'in yapmış olduğu karanlık oda
deneyindeki o deliğin önüne bir prizma
koyarak kendi gökkuşağını
oluşturabiliyor. Optikle ilgileniyor.
Yani bu dönemki bilim insanları sadece
fizikle ilgilenmiyor. Fiziğin bir alanı
matematik, kimya, başka disiplinleri de
birleştiriyor. Bunu da söylemeden geçmek
istemiyorum. Newton bu kütle çekim
kuvvetini, nasıl kütlelerin birbirini
çektiğini tanımladığında belki senin
yaşlarındaydı ve yine pandemiye denk
geldiği için senin yaşlarında üniversite
okurken kapatıldı, çiftliğine gitti,
orada sorgulamaya devam etti. Yani okul
sadece okulda olacak bir şey değil.
eğitimi sen kendin evinde de
sorgulayarak yapabilirsin. Hatta yeni
müfredat bizden bunu istiyor. Sorgula,
merak et, heyecan duy. Heyecanlı
olduğunu alanları bir öğren, kendini
sorgula istiyor. Böylelikle Newton'la
birlikte klasik fiziğin kapıları
açılıyor ve bütün evrendeki hareket
denklemlerini tanımlamış oluyoruz.
1700'lü yıllarda tarihte bunu daha iyi
bilirsin. Bu dönemde sanayi devrimi
oluyor. Sanayi devriminin ayrıntılarını
ardıçı tarih hocamdan dinlersin. Fakat
sanayi devrimi nasıl oluşuyor? bir
düdüklü tencere ile başlıyor. Düdüklü
tencerenin düdüğünden çıkan buhar acaba
hareketi sağlar mı diye yola çıkarak
1800'lü yılların ortalarında tren,
buharlı tren ortaya çıkıyor. Yani
insanlar bugüne kadar gemiyle seyahat
ediyorlardı. Onun dışında atla seyahat
ediyorlardı. İlk kez tren diye bir
ulaşım aracı insanoğlunun hayatına
girdi. Kilometrelerce öteye rahatlıkla
gidebildi insanoğlu ve bunu 1700'lü
yıllardaki basınç kavramları, enerji
kavramları ve ısı sıcaklık kavramlarıyla
yaptılar. Isı sıcaklık neydi?
Termodinamikti bizim için. Termodinamik
alt dalığımız da burada gelişmeye
başlandı diyebiliriz. Sanayi devriminin
sonunda aslında bu 1700'lerde kimyada
baş vermeye başlıyor. Element kavramları
ortaya çıkmaya başlıyor. 1800'lü
yılların başında da sanayi devrimi biter
bitmez Fransız ihtilalini gözlemliyoruz.
Fransız ihtilalinde maalesef giyotinle
kesilen kafalarla bazı arkadaşlarımız
deney yapmaya karar veriyor. Kurbağa
bacağının öldükten sonra bile kasılması
acaba insanoğlunda da var mıdır diye o
kesilmiş kafalarla deney yapan ikili
var. Galvani ve Volta. Tam deliler bu
sayede elektrik devrelerini
oluşturabildiler. Bu kasılmadan yola
çıkarak. He dediler. Galvani bugün bizim
elektrik devrelerinde kullandığımız
elektrik tellerine galvanik tel diyoruz.
Volta elektrik devrelerinde
kullandığımız pilin birimi olarak
geçiyor. Volt olarak ilk pili bize
göstermiş oluyor. Yani 1800'lü yıllarda
karşımıza elektrik ve manyetizma
kavramları çıktı diyebiliriz. Bu da bir
diğer alt dalımızdır diye konuşalım.
Franklin var 1700'lü yılların sonunda.
Franklin de ne yapıyor? İnsanoğlu yine
her zamanki gibi doğadan esinlenerek
bilim yaptığı için diyor ki ya bu şimşek
yıldırım neden oluşuyor? onu toprağa
iletebilir miyim diye ucuna anahtar
bağladığı bir uçurtma yapıyor ve buradan
artı ve eksi yüklerin tanımlamasını
yapıyor. Amper, Faraday bu arkadaşlar
manyetizmayile alakalı çalışmalar
yapıyor. Yang dalgalarla ilgili
çalışmalar yapıyor. Dalgaları senin 10.
sınıfın son konusunda göreceğiz. Kelvin,
termodinamik, ısı sıcaklıkta sıcaklığın
birimi olarak hemen bir sonraki
dersimizde işleyeceğimiz başlık kendisi.
Ohm, Edison, Tesla var burada. Bunlar
tamamen elektrik devrelerini artık daha
verimli hale getirmeye çalışıyorlar.
Nitekim Tesla ile birlikte doğru akımdan
alternatif akıma geçişi buluyoruz ve
elektriği kilometrelerce öteye kablolar
aracılığıyla iletebiliyoruz. Burada bir
de bahsetmem gereken Maxwell diye bir
arkadaş var. Hazır elektrik ve
manyetizma kavramları öğrenildiği için
Maxell bu elektrik alan ve manyetik
alanla ilgili çalışmalar yaparken çat
diye ışığın ne olduğunu buluyor ve artık
ışığı öğrenmeye başlamış oluyoruz. Yani
1800'lü yıllarda insanoğlu lambayla
tanışıyor. Yani artık akşamları mumda
veya bir kandil ışığında çalışmaktansa
lambayla dünya aydınlanıyor diyebiliriz.
Gelelim 1900'lere. Hazır ışığı öğrendik.
Işığı anlamaya başladık. Burada yine bir
isim var karşımıza çıkan. Mary Küri.
Mary hatta benim şu an stüdyomun adı.
Belki Instagram'dan takip edenler ya da
topluluktan takip edenler biliyordur.
Zedo stüdyolarında her hoca kendi
stüdyosuna bir isim verdi. Ben de
sizlerin seçtiği Meriküre'yi koymayı
uygun buldum. kendisi atomları
inceliyor. Uranyumu incelerken bir ışıma
yaptığını fark ediyor ve radyoaktiviteyi
aslında ilk konuşan isimlerden biri
oluyor. Kendisi tarihte bütün kadınlar
dışlanırken günümüzde bile iki tane
Nobel ödülü alan tek kadın olarak tarihe
geçmiş oluyor Mericürriy ve maalesef
radyoaktiviteden yani radyasyondan
kaynaklı hayatını kaybediyor. 1900'lerde
kimi görüyoruz? Einstein'ı, Boru,
Kampton, Debrogly, Heisenberg. Bunların
hepsi modern fizikte seninle yeni
müfredatta konuşacağımız isimler ama bu
yıl hiç görmeyeceğiz. Shirodinger'le
Heisenberg'le birlikte belirsizlik,
olasılık yasası hayatımıza giriyor. Var
mı yok mu? Bakarsam var, bakmazsam yok.
Bu hikayeler atomik seviyede alışık
olduğumuz klasik fizikten daha bağımsız
bir şekilde karşımıza çıkmakta. Ve bunun
peşine artık atomu tanıdık,
radyoaktiviteyi öğrendik. ışığın ne
olduğunu biliyoruz. Dünya savaşları baş
vermeye başlıyor. Bilim insanları
kaçırılıyor. Hatta ı Dünya Savaşı'nda da
nükleer bombadan dolayı artık savaş
dünya üzerinde bitmiş oluyor. Çünkü
nükleer silah gerçekten güçlü bir silah.
Biz bunu savaşta kullanırsak artık
yaşayacak bir dünyamız olmayacak diye
böyle yaptığımız savaşlar bir anda yön
değiştiriyor ve uzay savaşları başlıyor
diyebiliriz. Bu durumda sevgili
arkadaşım şöyle tüm tarihe baktığımızda
avcı toplayıcıdan başlayıp teknoloji
nasıl buraya kadar geldi? Şöyle 3 aşağı
5 yukarı bahsetmiş olduk. Şu 1900'lü
yıllarda gördüğümüz alt dallar neydi?
Atom fiziğiydi, katı hal fiziğiydi,
nükleer fizikti. Başka bir şey daha
vardı. Uzay savaşlarını gördün. Uzaya
roketi nasıl yolluyorduk? Yüksek enerji
ve plazma fiziği sayesinde yolluyorduk.
Buradan da yola çıkarak bizim fiziğin
alt dalları nelere bağlıymış?
konuştuğumuz bir yer olmuş oldu. Burada
başka önemli bir isim var mı hocam?
Einstein var bilmemiz gereken. Özellikle
MEAP kitabının bize sorabileceği isim
Einstein. Einstein ne yapıyor? kendisi
hem ışıkla hem de atomla hem de modern
fizikle alakalı son gelişmelerin öncüsü
olmuş oluyor. E= MC²are formülüyle
kütlenin büyük bir enerji kaynağı
olduğunu bize söylemiş oluyor. 1960'lara
geldiğimizde uzay savaşları, soğuk savaş
devam ederken diyorlar ki ya insanoğlu
birçok araştırma yaptı. Birçok bilim
yapıldı. Bunları bir standart haline
getirelim. SA Unit birim sistemi
kuruluyor. Bir sonraki dersimizde bizzat
bu kavramın ne olduğunu işleyeceğiz
seninle. Fizikte hangi kavramlar var?
Bunların birimleri neler? Dünya
standardında hangilerini konuşuyoruz?
Bunları anlatmış olacağım sana bir
sonraki derste. Geliyorum 2025'e.
2025'te artık teknoloji ve yapay zeka
biliyorsun ki yapay zekayı atom fiziğine
örnek olarak vermiştik. parçacık fiziği,
uzay bizim için bu gelişmeler arasında
yer almış oluyor. Hatta uzay fiziğinde
bugün senin bildiğin Stephen Hawking MEB
kitabında yer almakta. Uzayla alakalı,
kara deliklerle alakalı çalışmalar
burada gerçekleşmekte. Bizim için önemli
olan şey şu. Senin buradaki insanları,
isimleri ezberlemekten ziyade bu
insanların senin yaşında bir şeyler
bulabildiğini öğrenmen, bu insanların
senin yaşında merak duygularının
peşinden gittiğini öğrenmen, azimli ve
sabırla çalışmalarını devam
ettirdiklerini konuşabilmen bizim
adımıza en önemli kısım diyebilirim.
Hızlıca gelelim bilim merkezlerini
konuşmaya. Türkiye'de TÜBİTAK, Aselsan,
Tua ve ne var? Bir de MTA TTA var.
TÜBİTAK dediğimiz bilim projelerinin
yapıldığı, ARGI çalışmalarının olduğu
bir yer. Bugün sen de öğretmeninle bir
proje üretip TÜBİTAK'ta yer
alabiliyorsun. Aselsem askeri elektronik
sanayi demek. Askeri elektronik ve
haberleşme sanayi. Burada fizikçi
olabilirsin, kimyacı olabilirsin,
mühendis olabilirsin, hiç fark etmez.
Özellikle elektronik ve haberleşme
üzerine yapılacak çalışmalarda ARGE
sahasında ASELSAN'da çalışabilirsin. Bir
meslek sahibi olabilirsin. TUA var.
Türkiye Uzay Ajansı Alper Gezeravcı'dan
biliyorsundur diye düşünüyorum. Çok yeni
bir bilim merkezi bizim için ama uzayla
alakalı çalışmalarım buradan
yürüttüğümüzü bilmeni isterim. Bir
diğeri MTA direkt ODTÜ'nün yanındaydı.
Her ODTÜ'ye girdiğimde acaba burada ne
yapıyorlar diye merak ettiğim bir yerdi.
Maden tetkik arama. Sen burada herhangi
bir bilim insanı olarak madenleri nasıl
kullanabiliriz? Verimliliği nasıl
artırabiliriz? Çalışabiliyorsun. Bir de
TENM var. Türkiye Enerji Nükleer Maden
Araştırma Kurumu olarak adı üzerinde
enerji nükleer üzerine, maden üzerine bu
bilim merkezinde çalışabilirsin. Peki
hocam Türkiye dışında hangi bilim
merkezlerini bilmem gerekiyor? Uzayla
alakalı Amerika'nın uzay ajansı olan
NASA, Avrupa'nın uzay ajansı olan ESA
var. Onun dışında SERN bizim için
parçacık laboratuvar olarak geçmekte.
Yerin altında Avrupa'da, İsviçüre ve
Fransa sınırında yerin altında devasa
bir laboratuvar. Burada parçacıkları
hızlandırıp birbiriyle çarpıştırıp acaba
yeni bir madde üretebilir miyiz ya da
benim verimliliğimi artırabilecek bir
madde bulabilir miyim diye çalışmalar
yapılıyor. Hatta kimileri de korkuyor ya
acaba kara delik oluştururlar mı falan
diye. Sonra da bizim için parçacık
laboratuvarı. Dolayısıyla atom fiziğinin
geçerli olduğu yer, yüksek enerji ve
plazma fiziğinin geçerli olduğu yer diye
görülebilir. Biz sadece fizik okuyarak
buralarda bilim merkezlerinde
çalışabiliriz. Onun dışında öğretmen
olabiliriz, akademisyen olabiliriz.
birçok bilim insanı yetiştirebiliriz ve
bunların da ötesinde senin marif modelin
senden istediği, yeni müfredatın senden
istediği araştırmacı bir zihniyetsen
farklı yeteneklerini birleştirip bir
bankada da fizikçi olarak
çalışabilirsin. Nasıl hocam? Bir
fizikçinin bankada ne işi var? Fizikle
yazılımı birleştirip veri istatistiği
yapabilirsin bankada veya başka
alanlarda kendini geliştirebilirsin.
Fakat önemli olan şey senin üniversiteye
gitmen, bu soruları cevaplamandan ziyade
senin farklı yeteneklerini ortaya koyup
yeni bir öğrenme sürecini tamamlaman.
Öğrenmeyi öğrenmen. Yani fiziği öğrenmen
derdimiz değil. Bizim için önemli olan
sen bu fiziği sorguluyor musun? Bu
önemli. Bu arada biliyorum birçok kaynak
araştırıyorsun. Ben soru çözmeliyim.
Sınava hazırlanıyorum. Lütfen şunu
unutma. TYT ve YKS'den, AYT'den sen
sorumlu değilsin. Yeni sınav sistemimiz
ne olacak bilmiyoruz. Burada önemli olan
senin soru çözmen, LGS'deki gibi
binlerce kitap taraman değil. Senin bu
bilgileri özümsemen, senin bu bilgileri
tekrar etmen önemli. Ve aynı İbn
Heysem'in yaptığı gibi yapman gereken en
önemli nokta sen gerçek bilgiye
ulaşabiliyor musun? Gerçek bilgiyi
sorgulayabiliyor musun? Bir gerçek bilgi
ne demek? Bunu biliyor musun? O yüzden
lütfen dersini dinlerken kimden
dinlediğini iyi bil. Dinlediğin insanın
yeterliliğini iyi özümse. Kendin
sorgula. Kendin kriterlerini belirle.
Her denileni atlama. Ya dokuzlar şunu
yapmasın. Tamam. Kim diyor sana bunu?
Dokuzlar bunu yapmasın. Öğretmenlerini
dinle. Öğretmenlerine kulak ver.
Öğretmenlerinin de kendine uygun bir
şekilde söylemlerini hayatına geçir. Her
denileni yapma. gerçekten sorguladığında
kendi yaşıtlarından, diğer insanlardan
daha farklı olduğunu bileceksin.
Sorgulak, düşünmek en kolayı gibi ama
bence bir insanda olması gereken ve
maalesef sahip olunması gereken en zor
yönlerden bir tanesi. O yüzden dersi
kimden dinliyorsun? Dersin içeriğinde
bilgi ne kadar doğru veriliyor? Bunları
sorgulayarak ilerle. Bizim için ilk
ünitenin konu anlatımı tamamlandı. Şimdi
seninle birinci kısım yani fiziğin alt
dalları ve buradaki bilim merkezleriyle
bilime yön veren insanlarla alakalı
sorularımızı bir cevaplayalım hızlıca.
Nasıl yorumluyormuşuz görelim. Güneş
patlamalarının incelenmesinde ve
yorumlanmasında bilim insanları önemli
bir rol oynamakta. Bilim insanları
yıldızların oluşumu, gezegenlerin
hareketi, patlamadan sonra meydana gelen
sıcaklık değişimleri kuantum
bilgisayarlarından yararlanarak
açıklamaya çalışırlar. Uzaydan getirilen
numuneleri ve bunların molekül
yapılarını araştırırlar. Ayrıca uzaya
gönderilen cihazların hareketini,
hareket için gerekli enerjiyi ve kuvveti
formüllerle hesaplar. Çalışmalarını
sürekli test ederek deneme yaparlar.
Hangi alt dalından bahsedilmemiştir
diyor. Mekanik var mı? Bir sürü hareket
kavramı gördüm. Kesinlikle mekanik var.
Yüksek enerji ve plazma fiziği.
Yıldızların oluşumu dedi. Beni direkt
orada vurdu. Kesinlikle yüksek enerji ve
plazma fiziği dedim. Termodinamik
sıcaklık değişimi diyordu. Termodinamiğe
girer dedim. Optik bir dursun. Optiğe ne
demiştik? Işığın geometrisi demiştik.
yansıma kırılmayı bahsediyor demiştik.
Atom fiziğinde de şurada uzaydan
getirilen numuneler ve bunların molekül
yapıları deyince atom fiziği geldi
aklıma. Bana böyle aynayla alakalı,
görüntüleme cihazı ile alakalı bir
şeyden bahsetmediği için optikten
bahsedilmemiştir diyebildim. Yani biz
seninle bu sorularla birlikte fiziğin
ilk kısmını da tekrar edip nasıl
yorumlamamız gerektiğini öğrenmiş
olacağız. Soru 2. Bilimsel bilgiye
ulaşma yöntemlerinde bu yargılardan
hangileri yanlıştır? Bakalım. Akıl
yürütme ve yaratıcılık fiziksel deneyler
kadar önemli değildir. Belki senin
aklına şu geliyor ya hocam deney çok
önemliydi. Deney çok önemliydi. Evet ama
senin akıl yürütmen olmazsa, senin
yaratıcılığın olmazsa bizim için deney
yeterli değil. Bir kere deney yapabilmen
için ilk adımın akıl yürütme ve
yaratıcılık kesinlikle bu kadar önemli.
İki, takip edilmesi gereken tek bir yol
vardır. Bilim asla tek bir yoldan
gitmez. Bilim hatta doğruyu aramaz.
Bilim yanlışı arar. Nerede yanlış varsa
onu yanlışlayabiliyorsak bizim için
doğru o olur. Yani bugün ben sana 2 +
2'nin 4 olduğunu kabul ettirebiliyorum.
Çünkü bunun yanlış olduğu daha
ispatlanmadı. Anlatabiliyor muyum? Bilim
yanlışı kurcalar. Bilim her zaman hatayı
sever. Bir hata çıksın ortaya diye
bekler. O yüzden sen soru çözerken ay
ben yanlış yaptım, ay ben fiziği
anlamıyorum diye. Eğer ki vazgeçersen
zaten ilk baştan elenmiş oluyorsun.
Bilim yolculuğunda vazgeçmeyeceksin.
Başka yollar bulacaksın. Hayatındaki her
evrede bu böyle değil mi? Bir sorun var.
O sorunu çözebilmek için farklı
yöntemler araman lazım ki daha mutlu ol.
Tek bir yol değil. Birçok yol vardır. O
yüzden bu da yanlış. 3. Sistematik bir
yaklaşım gerektirir. Sistematik olmak
bizim için her bir aşamada önem arz
ediyor. O yüzden bu yanlış değil. 1 ve 2
yanlıştır. Bizim için doğru cevap C'dir
dedik. Devam edelim. 3ün soru biraz uzun
bir soru. Bu arada sevgili arkadaşım
konu PDF'lerini ben kitabı çıkartsam
dahi kesinlikle ücretsiz bir şekilde tüm
Zeyd öğretmenleri olarak seninle
paylaşacağız. Ancak soru kısımlarını
maalesef soruların telifinden kaynaklı
sıkıntı yaşadığımız için paylaşamıyoruz.
Sadece konu kısımları paylaşılmaya devam
edecek haberiniz olsun. Ama henüz
zannediyorum bu yıl kitap değil de PDF
üzerinden ilerleriz. Hem beraber
birbirimizi tanımış oluruz diye
düşünmekteyim. Örnek 3 ne demiş?
Yaklaşalım. Yusuf öğretmen öğrencilerine
fizik bilimine giriş ünitesinden 5
soruluk bir sınav hazırladı.
Öğrencilerinden günlük hayata dair
verdiği örneklerin fiziğin hangi alt
dalıyla ilgili olduğunu yazmalarını
istedi. Deniz'in sınav kağıdında sadece
bir hatası olduğunu fark eden öğretmen
yanlış cevabın üzerine çizdi. Hangi
cevabın üzerine çizdi? Hangisi yanlış?
Bakalım. Uzaya gidiş geliş süresinin
kısaltılması yani roket fırlatma. Uzayla
alakalı bir şey varsa yüksek enerji ve
plazma fiziği diyebiliriz demiştik.
Arkeolojik kalıntı. Arkeolojik kalıntıyı
gördün. Göbeklitepe dedik. Ne dedik?
çekirdek tepkimelerinden,
radyoaktiviteden yararlanarak
buluyorduk. O zaman bu nükleer fizik bir
kere bir dursun ama devamını da bir
okuyayım sorunun. Kuşların yönünü
bulabilmesi. Bunu cevaplayamaman çok
normal. Çünkü elektrik ve manyetizma
ünitezini bitirmen lazım daha net ifade
edebilmek için. Kuşlar, bazı
kaplumbağalar, karetta karettalar
dünyanın manyetik alanından yararlanarak
yönlerini bulmakta. Arılar işte o yüzden
elektromanyetizmayı burada kabul etmek
durumundayım. Fiberoptik kabloları zaten
direkt optiğe örnek vermiştik. daha
hızlı veri iletimini sağlıyor ışığın
yansıması sayesinde demiştik. Şarj
edilebilir piller katal fiziğin örnek
verdiklerimizden bir tanesiydi. Bu
durumda hoca atom fiziğinin üstünü
çizecek. Çünkü bunu yanlış yaptık. Ne
olmalıydı? Nükleer fizik olmalıydı. Bu
da uzun bir soru. Bu aslında bilimdeki
etik değerlerle alakalı bir soru. O
yüzden böyle bir paragraf sorusu
okuyormuş gibi anlamlandıralım.
Paragrafı eminim LGS'den çıkmış olan sen
çok seversin. Çünkü Türkçe ve matematik
tamamen okuduğunu anlamaya yönelikti. Bu
arada bir 9. sınıf öğrencisi olarak ille
test çözeceğim. Hocam ben okuduğumu
anlamak istiyorum. Bu öğrendiklerimi
pekiştirmek istiyorum diyorsan Türkçe ve
matematiğe yönlenmeni tavsiye ederim.
Türkçe saati Öznur hocamın kanalından
zemin hazırla paragraf kampını
kesinlikle izlemelisin. Kesinlikle o
soruları çözmelisin. Günde 5 tane de
olsa. SML matematik hocamdan da zemin
hazırla matematik kampını takip
etmelisin. 12 günlük bir kamp. Orada
temel işlemler, oran, orantı veya diğer
branşlar için gerekli olan matematikten
bahsediyorlar. İlle test çözeceğim
diyorsan bu iki derse, bu iki hocama
yönelmeni tavsiye ederim. Çünkü fizik
kısmını ben sana bu derslerle
hallettireceğim. Hiç merak etme. Soru
demiş ki, Arşimet hiç şüphesiz en büyük
bilim insanıydı. Arşimed'in bugün
dünyamızı görme şansı olsaydı ne bilimin
ne de teknolojinin geldiği nokta onu
fazla şaşırtmazdı. Hem üstün bir
matematikçi hem de yetkin ve becerikli
teknis olanan Arşimed'in icat ettiği
savaş aletleri sayesinde Romalılar
kuşatma altına aldıkları memleketini 3
yıl boyunca işgal edemediler. Basit
makineler falan yapıyor demiştik ya.
Sonunda işgal ettikleri günse 3 yılın
sonunda Arşimet çözmek için uğraştığı
bir matematik problemine o kadar
dalmıştı ki kendisini öldürmeye gelen
askerin farkına bile varmadı. Vay
anasını. Gerçekten güzel bir paragraf.
Yalnızca paragrafta verilen bu bilgilere
göre bilim insanları ile ilgili
hangileri çıkartılabilir? Bakalım.
Teorik bilgiye güvenmezler ve merak
ettikleri bir konuda gerçeği göstermek,
kanıtlamak için DN yaparlar. Evet, bu
bilim insanı özelliklerinden bir tanesi
ama ben bu paragraftan çıkartamadım.
Çalışmalarını sistematik bir şekilde
kayıt altına alırlar. Yine bu
paragraftan çıkarttığım bir şey değil.
Çalışmaları çok yönlüdür. Bak ne dedi?
Matematik dedi, fizik dedi değil mi?
Yukarıdaki paragrafta bir yandan icat
yaptı, basit makine üretti. Bir yandan
gitti matematik denklemi çözüyor falan.
Çok yönlü. Her an sorgulamaya, üretmeye
emek ve vakit ayırabilirler. Bunu
çıkartabilirim gibi geldi ama emin olmak
için diğer şıkları da okumak istiyorum.
Her zaman olaylara objektif şekilde
bakmaya çalışırlar. Evet, bilim insanı
özelliklerinden biri ama yine yukarıdaki
paragraftan çıkartamadım. Bilginin
sonsuz bir kavram olduğunu ve bugün
doğru olan bir bilginin yarın yanlış bir
bilgiye dönüşme ihtimalin olduğunu
bilirler. Yani son körü köründe
savunmazlar bir şeyi. O yüzden bu da
doğru bilim insanları için. Ancak
buradan çıkartamadık. Fakat bir baktık
ki Arşimet hem matematik hem fizik hem
başka alanlarla ilgilendi. Hem ülkesi
işgal altındayken oturdu ve çalışmaya
her an emek vakit ayırabildi. O yüzden
bu da güzel bir soru tipiydi. Geldik
soru 5'e. Üniversite tanıtım günlerinde
umarım bir gün sen de o günlere
ulaşacaksın. Gezen lise öğrencisi Ali,
astrofizik, biyofizik, jeofizik, nükleer
fizik, metafizik gibi isimleri duyunca
kafası karışıyor. Danışman öğretmeni ona
bu alanların genel çalışma alanlarını
özetliyor. Diyor ki, "Aşağıdakilerden
hangisi fizik biliminin alt dalı ile
ilgili değildir?" Bakalım. Astrofizik,
uzayda meydana gelen olayları incelemek.
Uzay, uzayla alakalı bir şey varsa belki
sen şöyle diyorsun ya hocam işte fizik
yazıyor. Banger direkt astrofizik
diyeyim ve fiziğin alt dalları bununla
ilgileniyor diyeyim. Şöyle hangi alt
dalı ilgileniyor diyebiliriz. Ben uzayı
gördüğüm için yüksek enerji ve plazma
fiziği dedim. Bu ilgilenebilir.
Biyofiziğe baktım. Canlı yapıları
fiziksel ilkeler çevresinde inceleyen
bir bilim dalı. Biyofizikte hatırlarsan
ilk dersimizde şey örneği vermiştim işte
fotosentez falan. Fotosentez için ışığın
nasıl geldiğini, nasıl yansıdığını,
nasıl absorbe edildiğini konuşuyoruz.
Dolayısıyla biyofizikte de işin içine
optik girebilir diye düşündüm. Nükleer
fizik maddenin iç yapısı ve çekirdekle
ilgili konu alır dedi. Nükleer fizik
zaten direkt fiziğin alt dalı. Metafizik
varlık ve evrenle ilgili soyut
kavramları açıklamaya çalışır dedi.
Şimdi metafizikte de fizik var. Hatta ne
demiştik? Bir de astroloji demiştik.
Astroloji. Bunlar sanki bilimmiş gibi.
Ancak bilimle hiçbir alakası yok. Gözlem
yok, deney yok. Bunların bilimle hiçbir
alakası yok. Kesinlikle cevabım
metafizik. Hocam bir de jeofizik var.
Jeo yer demek. Fizikte fizik yer bilimi
aslında. Hatta bunu en çok coğrafyada
görüyorsunuz. Jeofiziği. Coğrafyanın
kodları daha iyi anlatacaktır size.
Orada işte atıyorum deprem dalgalarını
konuşacaksın. Yerin yapısı bizim için
önemli. İşin içine fizik de giriyor.
Fizikle alakalı başka alt dallar
jeofizikte yer alabiliyor. Ancak
metafizik, astroloji bizim için fizik
değil. Daha çok felsefeye, tam felsefe
de diyemem. Giriyor. Üfürükçülüğe
giriyor bence. Ama neyse geçiyorum.
Şimdi astrologları karşıma almayayım.
İnan bana tli yıllarda hani şeyden
bahsetmiştik ya İbn Heysem'den falan. O
süreçte İbn Sina var, Farabi var. O
dönemde bile birçok kavga oluyor
astrolojiyle alakalı. Yok yıldız
falları, yok yıldızların konumlarına
göre karakter belirlenmesi falan. En son
İbn Sina 1000'li yıllarda şunu diyor ya
diyor astroloji ile ilgilenen ahmaktır
diyor. Bakın binli yıllarda bu bilgi
bize ulaşmış bir vaziyette. O yüzden
inanmayın. Jüpiter'in senin yarın
evleneceğin ya da bugün aşık olduğun
adamın karakteriyle ya da senin burcunla
onun burcunun uyumunun senin ilişkini ne
kadar güzelleştireceği ile alakalı
herhangi bir data yok bilimsel olarak. O
yüzden bunlara inanıp da hayatınızı ona
dair kurgulamayın. Tamam mı? Bunu ben
öğretmeniniz olarak bir fizikçi olarak
size baştan söylemiş olayım. Örnek 6.
Lise son sınıf öğrencisi Zeynep fizik
projesi için evrenin oluşumunu
araştırmaya karar veriyor. Öğretmenin
onun atom altı parçacıklarını
çarpıştırılarak gözlemlendiği
deneylerden bahsediyor. Atom altı
parçacıkları. Zeynep bu konuya daha
derinlemesini incelemek için dünyanın en
büyük parçacık fiziği laboratuvarı
nereydi hocam? Sn'de TÜBİTAK zaten
Türkiye'de. Aselsen Askeri Sanayi
demiştik. Tayekne Türkiye Atom Enerji
Kurumu NASA uzayla alakalıydı. O zaman
hocam cevabım Ceyhan. Çünkü en büyük
parçacık fiziği laboratuvarı s demiştik.
Orada yeni maddeler oluşturuyorlardı
mıknatıslarla hızlandırarak diye
söyledik. Bu soru ne dedi? Hangisini
çıkartabiliriz? Çölde yaşayan kum
akrepleri son derece ilkel gözlere sahip
olmalarına rağmen geceleri bile çok
rahat alınabilmektedir. Biyologlar bu
akreplerin bacaklarında bulunan bir
algılayıcı olduklarını keşfetmiş.
Günümüzde fizikçiler akrebin bu
algılayıcılarından gelen sinyalleri
işleyerek avlarının yerlerini nasıl
belirlediklerini ortaya koymuşlar. Bak
biyoloji ve fizik iki farklı disiplin
ilişki halinde. Dikkat. Fizik biliminin
diğer disiplinlerle ilişkili olduğunu
çıkartabilirim. Biyologların fizik
bildiklerini değil, akreplerin fizikten
yararlandığını değil, fizikçilerin her
şeyi açıklayabildiklerini değil,
biyologların sadece akrepleri
incelediklerini değil. Ne yaptık?
Biyoloji ve fizik burada ortak bir
alanda çalıştılar demiş olduk. Geldim
son sorumuza. Mürekkep balığı içine
çektiği deniz suyu ile kas boşluğunu
genişletir ve daha sonra kaslarını güçlü
bir şekilde sıkarak suyu dışarı atar.
Suyun çıkış yönüne ters yönde. Saatte
yaklaşık 40 km hız eden hızlı hareket
eden mürekkep balığının bu hareketini
açıklayan fiziğin alt dalı. Hareket,
denge, kuvvet bizim için neydi sevgili
arkadaşım? Mekanikti. Hocam daha fazla
konuşmaya gerek yok. Dikkat edersen bu
ünitede daha yoğunluklu gelen soru sana
nereden geldi? Fiziğin alt dallarından
geldi. Alt dallarını yorumlamayı
bileceğiz. Onun dışında bu tarihçeden de
bir iki ismi bileceğiz. Hatta gel bunu
sana MEB kitabından göstereyim.
Hangileri önemli diye biz şu kısmı
seninle tamamlamıştık. Fiziğin alt
dallarını konuşmuştuk. Fizik bilimine
yön verenlerden İbnül Heysem'i gördün.
Kepler, Galilo'yu, Newton'ı gördün.
Einstein'ı gördün. Devam ediyorum.
Burada bilim insanlarının özelliklerini
sözel olarak konuşuyorsun. Faraday
manyetizmanın temelini atmıştı. Maxwell
dalgaların, ışığın bir elektromanyetik
dalga olduğunu söylemişti. Bunları çok
rahat cevaplayabiliyorsun. Hani 1900'lü
yıllardan sonra atom fiziği falan
gelişti demiştik ya. Hatta 1960'lardan
sonra bizim için uzay savaşları artık
piyasada var olmaya başladı. Stephen
Hawking son yıllarda tanıdığım bir bilim
insanı. Daha birçok bilim insanı var.
Aziz Sancar gibi 1900'lü yıllarda
kuantum fiziği biraz daha insanları
sorgulattığı için bugüne kadar alışık
olduğumuz klasik fizikten daha farklı
bir fizik olduğu için bunları anlatan
Richard Finman gibi veya Paul Havit gibi
fiziği öğretmek adına, fizik
öğretmenlerine bir şeyler öğretebilmek
adına bunlar da bizim için çalışmalar
yapmış bilim anlatıcıları diyebiliriz.
Bu bilim anlatıcıları da bilim insanları
yerine geçmektedir. Çünkü bilimi sadece
yapmak değil aktarabilmek de önem arz
etmekte. Nitekim Stephen Hawking de yine
bizim için uzayla, kara deliklerle, kara
cisim ışımalarıyla uzayın arkasını
araştıran bilim insanlarından bir
tanesi. Bak burada yine bilim
insanlarının özelliklerinden
bahsedilmekte. Hedeflerinin peşinden
gitmesi, kararlı olması, çalışkan
olması, sabırlı olması, azimli olması.
Yani hocam ay liseye geçtim. Ay yeni
Maarif model. ay ben bu konuyu
anlamıyorum değil. Biraz sabır, biraz
gayret, biraz çalışmak. Yapamayacağın
hiçbir şey yok. Yani gerçekten bir
engelin yoksa sen Türkçe biliyorsan,
okuduğunu anlayabiliyorsan fiziği de çok
rahat yapabilirsin. Bunu lütfen unutma.
Einstein bizim için zaten son yüzyıldaki
en önemli bilim insanlarından dedik.
Bunları yaptık. Kariyer keşfi sana
burada uzun uzun laboratuvarlar
anlatılıyor. Bu laboratuvarların minik
minik zaten özelliğinden bahsettik.
oturup da ya hangi yılda kuruldu, hangi
kaç bin çalışanı var değil de temel
olarak neyi araştırıyorlar bu bilim
merkezlerinde onlara dikkat etmek lazım.
Onun dışında %90 sorumlu olduğun yer
fiziğin alt dalları. Başka bir şeye
gerek yok. Bu sayede bu üniteyi bitirmiş
oluyoruz seninle. Sayfa 49'a kadar
kitabındaki her yeri kurcalayabilirsin.
Yapamadığın bir yer olursa bana
yorumlarda sorabilirsin. Hocam kitabında
şu etkinliği yapamadım. Hocam şunu
cevaplayamadım gibi. Çünkü map kitabını
direkt çözemiyoruz. O da telife giriyor
arkadaşım. Ama ben sana özellikle
ilerleyen seneler için hazırladığım
kitapta Map kitabındaki etkinlikleri de
yer aldırmaya gayret ediyorum. Umarım
anlatabilmişimdir. Umarım açıklayıcı
olmuştur. İlk üniteyi tamamladık.
Yazılıdan önce bir de kuvvet hareketin
ilk kısmını bilmemiz gerekiyor. Onu da
önümüzdeki hafta seninle paylaşmış
olacağım. Başka türlü içerikler
istiyorsan hocam konuşalım, hocam sohbet
edelim. Hocam rehberlik yapın, hocam
soru çözün gibi. Lütfen bana yorumlarda
bildir. Ben de ona göre planlama
yapayım. Sen neyi talep ediyorsan ben de
ona göre sana bir şeyler oluşturayım. Bu
benim için en önemli kısım. Videoları
beğenmen, videolara yorum yazman beni
motive edecek. Ben de sana ücretsiz bir
şekilde ders anlatmaya devam edeceğim.
Zedu öğretmenlerine desteğini muhakkak
bekliyorum. Bir diğer dersimizde
görüşünceye kadar kendine iyi bak. Hoşça
kal.
[Müzik]